facebook and instagram users who feel
that harmful content has been
wrongly allowed to remain online will be
able to appeal
to have it removed the platform's
independent oversight board announced
tuesday
it will now start accepting such
requests
enabling users to appeal content they
want to see removed from facebook
is a significant expansion of the
oversight board's capabilities
we expect everyone on facebook and
instagram to be able to appeal content
left up
over the coming weeks well the move
significantly broadens the powers of the
supervisory body
prior to that it could only ask facebook
to reinstate content
the latest move comes after the social
media giant faced pressure including
from congress
to act on misinformation and abusive
content in particular
that's seen during the pandemic the 2020
u.s elections
and after the january 6 capitol hill
riot
the decision sparked online criticism
though with accusations facebook is just
trying to evade responsibilities
oversight board you are a non-binding
entity
whose only purpose is to deflect blame
for
facebook's shameful policies and severe
lack of moderation
in exchange for six-figure salaries wow
facebook and instagram literally has a
propaganda and censorship board
creepy i'm in the process of assembling
an oversight board to handle my business
affairs
in the future i cannot be sued or held
responsible for anything
because the board authorized it everyone
should have an oversight board
well facebook itself is sort of acting
like a government i mean
in ways it's richer more powerful than
many world governments
it appears to be that they want to put a
layer
between themselves the company facebook
uh mark zuckerberg and his company
and the the censorship and the content
so they can have this
this um this board if you will uh that
they've sort of said is independent
from them make the decisions for them it
protects them in a lot of ways
from uh from seeming like they are the
ones censoring they're the ones uh
manipulating content and what people see
and do
uh the way they're attempting to get
around this is by saying that this
commission this board whatever they want
to call it is completely independent
um but uh we have yet to see how exactly
it's independent
we don't really know who's on it how
they were appointed and
how close they are with facebook as a
company